but everybody another YouTube hang out
super excited me back with you guys here
today I've got a special guest with me
Daniel James he is a student at the
University of Maryland he is doing a
course on entrepreneurship and his
project was to interview an entrepreneur
that he respects and ask some questions
to and put together a couple pages on so
he chose me and I'm super humbled and
grateful for that and Daniel man over to
you I know the super nervous your first
time doing this think it is a great job
you got supportive everybody watching I
hit me up with your first question let's
get into it all right thank you how did
you get the idea or concept of your
business um for this one it came out of
frustration as an entrepreneur I was I
had a company octane I was not making
money and I almost quit I told my
partner that I quit and then I you know
went home and I cried and Wow was one of
the worst days of my life and the next
day I got up and like you know what I
can't quit like I gotta I gotta keep
going I gotta do this they I just have
to find another way to succeed cuz this
is like what I'm doing now sucks you
know make a few hundred dollars a month
really sucks oh and after so then we you
know we started to succeed he started to
get more clients here to build the
business but I was frustrated that there
wasn't a lot of content a lot of help
for someone like me who was going
through those issues and building the
business and I felt like I just wanted
to contribute and get back to other
people who are starting up a business so
that they don't quit because I almost
did and uh that was a start you know I
got invited to do some speaking after I
sold my company I did a volunteer thing
with the ymca to try to help
entrepreneurs and so the origin was out
of my frustration with my level of you
know success in the early days and I
wanted to help out other entrepreneurs
and when I started doing it I just loved
it like I fell in love with helping
entrepreneurs
hers and I needed to find a way to keep
going I didn't have plans for some big
huge thing that would spiral out of
control and you know the YouTube channel
all that wasn't the initial plan to just
I wanted to help and then I loved
helping so i had to find a way to do it
on a bigger scale that's pretty sad
thank you oh he's agreed i was reading
on your website you say that she started
biotech company and you sold it and i
was wondering was two of the background
about it yeah so uh i didn't start the
company i became an owner of the
business I was in University what year
when your University of you in this is
my senior year senior year okay so I was
I was in I was in university I was in my
third year undergrad and I thought I
want to be a banker like my high school
year because I going to be a banker
that's what my all my courses were about
my that's where my trajectory was being
a banker and I connect with two people
at my university who had started the
software company and I joined as an
owner to do more the business side of
things to help set up marketing
partnerships and distributor and media
and all that kind of stuff so that was
the start I wasn't my idea it wasn't my
business it sorry became my business
doesn't became an owner but I didn't
start it it wasn't my my idea from the
start um and it just was something that
was a test like I thought I want to be a
banker he was another opportunity i was
curious about it and i thought you know
what i want to give it a shot see what
happens and again i fell in love with
that and i had to find a way to keep
doing it what is the driving force
majeure entrepreneurship and endeavors
the driving force uh
I have so I'm a heart and a head one the
the heart one is I just love being able
to have an impact there's something
about helping entrepreneurs just helping
people in general right like I people
around me I want to get better at what
they're doing I want them to start
chasing their goals chasing their dreams
having an impact in the world it fuels
me the way that I can do that is to
entrepreneurship because that's the
knowledge that I have but if I was a
piano teacher or a soccer coach or
something else you know I would want to
make sure that the people around me were
growing in their panel or growing in
their soccer it's something that you
know I believe in people I believe in
their potential and the thing that
upsets me the most in the world is
untapped potential people playing below
where they could play and so the lens to
which I achieve that is to
entrepreneurship but if you if you are
in my ecosystem you need to rise and get
better period and so that drives me on a
mental level you know I believe
entrepreneurs are the ones we're going
to change the world I think I don't
think it's the politicians I don't think
it's the big corporations I think it's
the entrepreneurs every major problem in
the world would be solved by
entrepreneurs from hunger to you know
diseases everything and so the more that
I can have an impact helping
entrepreneurs the more that ripples out
to have a big impact on the world so
that's what drives me sounds good
there's a lot of people who struggle
with passion like when I was when I was
a high school I used to play basketball
then I had a lot of passion but I had a
lot of fallout swear I heard my knees
and stuff like that so now I'm kind of
like stagnant I don't have any pageant
brain thanks I'm kind of cruising
collect what would you recommend to
increase passion yeah that that's a
that's a tough one especially when you
lose something that you love my
suggestion is to go and explore
22 stop like if you can't play
basketball anymore maybe there's
something in basketball that you could
do like if you still love vascular maybe
his coaching maybes analytics maybe it's
training maybe something else but you
can't play the game anymore to like if
that is that is over because you don't
have the ability anymore then stop
living in the past right like stop
blaming your knees or that injury or
whatever you gotta move on like you got
to put the ex-girlfriend behind you to
move on and find the next one and find
the girl in your dreams and fall in love
right the the more you live in the man
she was so great mode you're never going
to be able to move on to find that right
person the more you just keep getting
lost and that I love basketball so much
i love planning I can't do it if that's
your story you're never going to move on
and find something else so having that
mindset shift then if you don't know
what to do you got to go and try stuff
say yes the things you know for me one
of the things here is an example one
year I wanted to do dancing and so I
went and did salsa dancing and on paper
it's a stupid thing like I'm 62 63 like
your take huge steps you know clumsy
never danced before salsa is Spanish I
don't speak Spanish I never heard the
music before it looks like the worst
thing on on paper logically for me to go
and do but I went and I fell in love
with it and I'm still dancing you know a
decade later I acquired the largest
salsa dancing school probably in North
America and became a big business
venture for me you know because I just
said yes to something at the same time I
said yes to going rock climbing and I
hated it I'm afraid of heights you know
I had the thing like in my crotch and
constricted and I didn't like it I so I
dropped out immediately I also went
snowboarding and I loved it at the start
and then over the years I lost interest
in it so sometimes you don't know you
just kind of say yes and try things
until you find the thing that makes you
come alive but you're not going to get
it just by thinking about it you're not
going to get it by sitting on the couch
and just researching you
go out and do something and knowing that
you have an inner genius right jay-z
says everybody has genius inside of them
you gotta go and find it knowing that
that's inside you that the world has not
seen the best of Daniel James yet that
should drag you to go out and do
something figure out what that next path
is for you and maybe it's still a
basketball just doing a different role
or mean it's totally outside maybe maybe
like even doing this is great right like
you asked me to answer ten questions on
email I said hey why don't we do this as
a hangout on video you're probably
nervous and haven't done that before but
you said yes right like maybe you come
on here and you fall in love with this
and like man I love that I'm going to go
do more interviews I'm going to go you
know to some other people that I look up
to and respect and asked him to doing
interview and you follow that flow or
maybe this is like the worst experience
of your life you know I never wonder
interview ever and you know you stop
doing it it's all good like get you get
some certainty by trying and so when you
have other opportunities come your way
like kudos to you for saying yes to this
because a lot of people don't say yes
and tries like be willing to try
anything once until you find the thing
that you fall in love with I want to
continue to explore I think a lot of
people put too much pressure at the
start to say this has to be my thing
like if I went to that salsa club or
that class is that this has to be my
next thing I would have put too much
pressure you go on a date with a girl
like this has to be the one that I'm
going to marry you don't know up to the
first date right like don't put that
much pressure on yourself to find the
next thing just go in see if you like it
see if you want to continue doing it you
know when I walked away from to my first
presentation to entrepreneurs like man
that was awesome I want to do that again
and when you find that thing then
continue on even if it doesn't make
sense you don't know how it's all going
to work out that's the path that's how
you find the thing that Daniel James is
going to be the LeBron James of in his
business thank you very much oh I want
to go into this question now how do you
select partners
for a business venture with you so
vastly have you yeah that's a great
question I think a lot of people have it
half right I think a lot of people say
you know I'm great at marketing and I
need someone who's great at the product
so I'm going to creating the product by
suck at marketing i need the marketing
guy or girl to come in and save me so
all you do is look at skill sets right
where that's a great place to start
recognizing what your week at and
surround yourself with people who are
strong at those things so that that's
the easy answer the hard part is also
understanding the values you need
someone who believes the same thing as
you do who treats people the same way as
you do who sees the world the same way
as you do just like if you were you know
get into relationship you're gonna you
know you're not going to marry somebody
just because of they fit this profile
right you go to eat harmony and like
they match up on here like okay they
look great on paper you don't know till
you actually meet with them right sorry
and you go through some tough times and
if you shared totally different values
it's not going to work out and so that
happens on a lot in business ventures
where you partner up with somebody this
looks great on paper but then when it
comes down to how you treat people and
what is most important to you if there's
a big gap in values then it's not going
to work out and so the easiest thing to
do with the best thing to do is to start
small just like you date before you get
married start small do one small thing
with a potential partner see how you
like did you guys fight all the way
through it or did you really vibe off
each other like this is this is really
good you know you're you got stalked in
them alone I don't know if that's too
old a basketball reference for you uh
but you know whatever like dynamic duo
on the basketball court maybe you know
maybe looks good to have stocked this
little guy who can dribble the ball and
pass it off him alone the bigger guy
who's got the hook shot and can go in
but just because like one guy is little
and can dribble and just because the
other guy you know can score doesn't
mean that when you put them together
it's going to work out
do it on paper isn't enough you've got
to actually test it out and try and see
if it works thank you I would definitely
use that next to find my next girlfriend
okay what had been the most surprising
part about starting a business the most
surprising part for me about starting a
business I think for me when I first was
starting out it was easy to think about
the money I thought business is about
money I thought even a job I thought
getting the job was about money how much
money you can make how quickly you can
make it where I realized after studying
success like studying all these people
behind me and by being in the business
that yes money is important but the
people who've had the most success are
the ones who don't make money their main
priority hoop the people who love
playing like the people have the most
success in basketball love basketball
they love the game like they're in there
they show up early they take the shots
because they love the game if you do it
just has a job is never going to work
out and so whether it's Michael Jordan
or LeBron James or whoever it is they
work hard because yes they're chasing
the championship and they have the goal
they want to win but at the core they
love they love basketball like they
don't they can't imagine your life
without doing that game and so you have
to love what you're doing you have to
love the work not just the outcome I'm
standing there at the free-throw line at
four in the morning practicing my jump
shot because I love practicing my jump
shot because I want to get better at it
not just being attached to the goal so a
lot of people have these goals of I want
to be a millionaire by the time I hit X
years old and whatever it takes for me
to get there I'll do the crappiest jobs
whatever it doesn't matter as long as I
hit my goal you'll never hit the goal
we're really if you enjoy the process
then that goal will happen and that's
something that they don't teach you in
school and it's something that I had to
learn from studying the greats and from
my own success my own entrepreneurial
ventures when you enjoy the process of
it then you'll get results yeah I
definitely agree with that i started
going in business school because I was
motivated by money and then what's that
study in accounting I realized okay this
is not going to take me down long
because I'm not really passionate about
accounting so I switched my major to
management and information system Naruto
I feel a little better with technology
and stuff like that so I definitely
really done it cool good lesson to learn
early because a lot of people get stuck
on that career path never figure it out
then you're 45 years old you know with
the spouse and kids and it's too late to
jump back off in the other path yeah one
source of funding did you find work
where are the sources of one was you
looking for and the word where they only
ones available ah so in general not a
big fan of spending money till I'm
making money I hate that as a concept
because you usually spend it on the
wrong things I much rather test
something small you know see if it's a
fit like if I wanted to say my goals I
want to be a basketball player okay you
know up before I get started I'm going
to go out and buy the dopest shoes I
gotta get the jersey I gotta get the
towel I gotta get like everything I've
got to look like a LeBron before I even
go out on the court and then I get on
the court and I take a jump shot and you
know what I eat this basketball thing so
for me you spent all this money doing
right like so that's how a lot of
entrepreneurs approach their business is
I'm going to start on YouTube but before
I do that I need the camera and the gear
and the light in they start spending
spending spending forever making
anything when the best thing is going to
court take a shot play a game of pickup
see if you like it and if you do then
you stick with it and then you can start
buying in an impact right uh where you
know too many people do the opposite
spend before they're making anything and
then you end up with 10,000 t-shirts in
your mom's basement and a huge loan
because you were convinced and t-shirt
thing was going to take off and it
doesn't right uh so I'm a big fan of a
lot of tests but small tests see if it's
see if you fall in love with us he was
it fit for you and you don't don't spend
money until you're making money business
is made business is supposed to be
making you money not costing you money
so find a way to do that and then use
the money you're making to help you grow
believed in and I never had to take
money for for my company we built it up
we sold it without me having it was all
it was all self-funded we put in our
hustle you know make it 300 bucks a
month as we made money we put it back
into the business and it grew I then
joined the venture capital company after
I sold my company to learn about the
process of raising money how do how do
you do it because I was curious about it
but I didn't we helped raise half a
million the 15 million for companies who
wanted to grow but I never had to do it
personally and then when I started this
this business I didn't raise any money
either and I'm i still take that
approach like I started on YouTube I had
a successful business I could have gone
out and got all the gear videos were
with my camera you know I spent zero
until I started making some money and I
poured that back into the channel has a
really smart mark you're insane only
morons take loans to start a business
that I don't know if you agree with that
yeah i do i'm not a fan of going into
debt man like don't go into debt to
start a business invest your hustle your
energy your heart your jive but not your
dollars until you start making something
okay what kind of personality do you see
mostly successful entrepreneurs I think
is a big misconception around this I
think I think you look at a cuban you
look at a trump you look at a branson
you look at these people who are you
know loud and on TV a lot and feel like
oh i'm not i'm not dynamic i'm not a
type-a personality i'm not the outgoing
guy or girl you don't have to be like
that you know you you see those people
standing up because that's what they're
good at like you know uh Cuban should be
loud and Cuban should say outlandish
things and should take a stance because
that's what he is good at right and so
you see those people leveraging what
they're great at where if you looked at
the the list of the wealthiest people a
lot of them are entrepreneurs who
started with nothing they come from all
sorts of backgrounds it's a ton of
introverted people who who you've never
heard of because their strength is not
been in front of the camera their
strength is in operations or in
analytics or you know all the detailed
stuff so I think a lot of people feel
like they have to be like human to get
there are any any of the Sharks or any
of the people you see interviews up
where it's absolutely not true the key
thing though is that you have to have an
idea and you have to get started too
many people have ideas like everybody
has an idea I'm sure you Dan you'll have
an idea for what you can do as a
business everybody has an idea most
people die with that idea still in them
then never else you take any action on
it so you have to have an idea you got
to take action and you're going to not
quit that's it you do that you'll have
success it may not be on the first one
maybe I'll be in a second one but
eventually it'll happen where a lot of
entrepreneurs the thing that keeps them
going is the love for what they did and
eventually that business becomes
something that they can be proud of so
what you recommend is most entrepreneurs
and resilience they don't quit visually
yeah under percent you got a you got it
you got to be persistent if you're an
entrepreneur you have to be persistent
cuz it's going to be one of the hardest
thing you ever do in your life I mean
look easy by looking all these success
stories but it's going to be way harder
than you thought you know your worst
case scenario is ever going to be you
got to keep on and the thing that lets
you keep on is the absolute sheer joy of
the process the love of the work how do
you feel about business plans I have
mixed feelings about business planes uh
for me right in the perf
big business plan cost me 40 million
dollars in my first venture that I lost
because I didn't get the deal I think
business plays are important you need to
you need to plan ah but understand that
there is no perfect business play that
you know you can't know until you
actually go and test and get out into
the market you can sit there and say you
know this is the best business idea ever
and sit there in your dorm room and
figure that out but until you actually
won't start executing then then you
don't know on every successful business
changes they're playing you look at
where business start and what ends up
making them massive successful there's
always a change or multiple changes
somewhere now this doesn't mean don't
have a plan like it's helpful to have a
plane I think in general there are
people who love planning and they're
going to spend months we're going on the
perfect business plan we're really they
should be spending more time taking
action in that extra you know three
months of writing the business plan you
could have hustled a lot for your
business thing in the girl and then
there are other people who just take
action and don't play and they're all
over the place and they never get
anywhere either because they need to
plan a little bit more to have some
structure for what they're doing so
usually people fall into one of those
two capes if you're a planner you need
to take more action if you're a doer
need to plan a little bit more so
recognizing where you are and having the
courage to go on the other side will
help you get more success in your
business I will wait okay I think your
incidents I was not asking what were
your responsibilities as a business
owner very I thought you already
answered at first my responsibilities as
Yasim is on in the first position now
yeah you got your being a day of
operation what do you do a daily basis I
think as you grow a business so let's
see at the start of the business you got
to figure out what is the highest value
that i can bring like what is missing in
the market that i can bring that will
add the highest value because
entrepreneurs have to do everything
you're everything from the janitor to
the CEO you're everything you got to do
it all and so where is
thing that you could be the LeBron James
of in your industry and then try to
focus as much time on that as possible
if you're spending ninety-five percent
of your time doing day-to-day admin crap
and five percent of your time being
LeBron James in your business you know
it's gonna take you so long they going
so you want to try to flip that right at
least you want to be an eighty percent
of your times being LeBron James and
twenty percent doing the rest so as a
solo entrepreneur that is the fastest
way for you to get going so like if
you're if you're selling a new shoe as
an example what is your strength is it
going to be in the salesmanship like
you're going to get on TV and pump it
out and go to go to meetings and go to
network in the bed and go to conferences
and talk people up because that's what
you're great at or is it going to be on
the marketing side and the data and
analytics and running facebook ads you
know or you don't have to talk to
anybody you're just lost in the sights
and the numbers but either them can work
it's more where's your strength because
if you are an introverted guy who loves
numbers and data and analysis and I put
you in a room to go to a sales call or
get on TV you're going to sock you're
going to feel uncomfortable it's not
going to be the best it's not going to
be your fastest path so understanding to
have that self awareness of where you
could really do well and going all in on
that as you build the business as you
bring on a team recognizing that your
highest value is going to be in bringing
up the people on your team like as you
scale your company you have people under
you you bring less value than like with
every person that you hire you bring
less and less value to the business it's
the team that's doing the work so you
have to motivate them you got to inspire
them you got to understand what makes
them tick you got to put them in the
right rules you got to top their ideas
to help the business grow so I mean I
still hustle a lot i'm still doing
videos constantly I'm grinding every day
in my company but by bringing on my team
I'm able to go from one video a week
where I'm doing everything to three to
five videos a day because I'm doing only
one small part of my team does the rest
so at the very beginning
it's what are you the best at that you
can really focus on and then as you grow
my responsibilities are mostly to my
team to make sure that they are growing
as well do you think there's a way to
switch from being introverted or
extroverted uh I don't know that's an
interesting question and may surprise
you but i'm i'm an introvert wow I'm i
hate I don't like I don't go to
conferences I don't go I don't talk to
the guy next to me on the airplane I
hate introduce myself at networking
events um the thing that is different
for me is for most people i won't i
won't be rude to them but i don't i
don't go up and introduce myself so i'm
not i'm not the sales guy i'm much more
in the marketing side so understanding
that about myself i create the
opportunity for people to discover me so
i can go and do a speech or get on that
TV show or you know whatever it is and
within if you talk about most things I
don't really care about but you if I
find out that you're an entrepreneur man
we're going to have a talk like I light
up it's my thing I love it so much and
that helps me overcome shyness or fear
or whatever it else where most people
are you talking about movies or even
basketball or other stuff like I'm not
you know I'll have a conversation but
i'm not i'm just going to be a active
listener but if you are an entrepreneur
you want to talk entrepreneurship or you
want to talk about the Toronto Blue Jays
are you want to talk about league of
legends and I'm going to I'm going to
turn up and get it excited and
interested so I think finding what you
love helps you be the best version of
yourself doesn't turn me into an
extrovert be the the most animated most
turned up version of me ellen degeneres
is an injured worker we did a great top
10 on her that you can check out when
you wouldn't think that she's
introverted yeah we're but again like
you watch that well yeah I love that
when I was surprised too that she's an
introvert um I would also say like be
proud of being an introvert like you
don't need to be an extrovert if you try
you're gonna it's not worth it like
you're you're trying to you're trying to
play football when you should be doing
basketball more you just play football
the more disappointed you're going to be
in yourself where you want to be the
best version of you and that's going to
come by honing in your strengths and
what you really enjoy so nothing wrong
with being an introvert I love being an
introvert I'm proud that I'm introverted
I will shout that all day long and I'm
introverted and so you gotta be you know
like recognize it that's your strength
it's not your weakness that's your
strength and going all in on those
things will help you start to make a
difference so the best thing is not to
try to change yourself for people to
like you but for you to be yourself and
people for people who love you right
yeah I think I think about changing
yourself it should not be to other
people's expectations of you it's
changing yourself to be the best version
of you so it's not just staying where
you are cuz you still gotta grow there's
still a lot of Daniel James left out
there man you you haven't hit your
ceiling or anywhere close to it you got
used to as a lot of hustle and growth
left in you but it's not because I think
that you need to be an entrepreneur or
your mom thinks that you need to be a
scientist or you know that that cute
girl things that you should you should
get on the swim team or whatever it is
right you're doing things because you
want to do it you want to enjoy you want
to learn and try to grow through it you
know I have all these people my wall
here different personalities different
backgrounds like I don't you know Howard
Schultz but he's a pretty straight-laced
CEO of Starbucks at the far corner you
got Kanye West where there's nothing
straight-laced about cutting yeah he's
going to turn up I like how do these
people both fit on the wall doesn't make
sense but it's like I could take stuff
from each of these people to make me the
best version of me so you know you may
like something about what I'm saying and
you could pull that to help you know you
get better
but you you're not going to be great by
being the next seven Carmichael for the
next you know Kanye or Steve Jobs or
whatever you got to be the best Daniel
James and you can do that by pulling
from different people so yeah I mean you
got to continue to grow you got to
continue to change but according to your
own expectations not the pressures that
other people are putting on you nothing
not sure okay I think we have a minute I
had 11 let that one more question for
you he worked what are the most
fascinating things and then these
fascinating things about being an
entrepreneur I think I think the most
fascinating thing is you get the chance
to do your own thing you know you get
the chance to break out of the box and
try something new and bet on yourself
and not have to work for the man and not
be told what to do and if you having a
creative idea you can go out and chase
it I think that is one of the ultimate
luxuries and most interesting things
about being an entrepreneur I think if
you're one of the least fascinating
things this might be unexpected is quite
often entrepreneur's will box themselves
in where you've been doing something you
want to try something new can you gonna
set the daniel james youtube channel you
get all excited and you're interviewing
people and you're learning hustling
growing and then you know what after
like two years of doing the same thing
you're going to start to get bored
you're gonna you're gonna feel like ah
you know I've been doing the same thing
for two years the same people uh I want
to change but you feel like you can't
because you brought all these people
with you how these customers you have
this audience and you need to continue
to innovate where a lot of entrepreneurs
stop and they get bored of their
business after a couple years and it's
really because they grew as a person but
their business didn't grow with them and
so you know you might start off you know
like you did like hey I want I want to
go and do a business school right I'm
going to go into County like I want to
be an entrepreneur I want to make money
and maybe you have some success at the
start but then with time you get your
bored of it like hey you know what I
don't like accounting I don't that's not
mean I get bored by the
numbers I don't want to go into that
more to have the courage to switch to
something else is what a lot of people
don't do they have the courage to start
but especially like is especially harder
if you were doing well in a county like
hey you're getting you're getting you're
getting A's are you getting a good you
know GPA in your accounting class but
didn't realize you know what like I
don't want to keep doing this man I like
I'm tired of accounting to leave that to
go try something else is hard but that's
what you need to do to continue to
continue your growth you know like
Jordan in the start of his career he's
dunking all over everybody you know as
he gets older he also can't dunk as much
anymore right like he's gotta change up
his game he's got to do the fate of ways
you know he's got to adapt um where's
don't adapt enough at the start like at
the start date they start something new
because their passion about it they're
excited but as they grow they don't
change their business alongside with it
alright circus that's all the questions
I have for you sir thank you very much i
love it will good luck with the project
man uh I just got to be online anywhere
like you publish it it's just for your
class oh I don't think I would publish
yet I think I want to pull my face out
there for fifo keza I don't know if you
never know dude you did great man you
did great I don't know wait maybe I
might get a good job or something you
yeah get a great job man or with
anything you do just just bring the
curiosity bring the passion you know
whatever questions you're asking make
sure that the genuine ones that you want
to learn from and whatever you apply
that to business career the next sport
whatever it is you'll uh you'll have
success as long as it's a genuine
enthusiasm for it so good luck thank you
for the courage for coming on to do this
you're getting a lot of love in the
comments people are wishing you out good
luck to so enjoy the rest of week man
congratulations to believe I listened